How often are you calling BO's after closing them to make sure they're happy?
I've just got an email saying, can we chat about a few things?
Hopefully he's not going to cancel out there two months.
Oh, don't you guys love when you get those emails, those convert, those text messages?
Sometimes it's from your clients.
Sometimes it's from your wife or your spouse or your significant other.
Or I remember being a kid and my dad would be like, we got to go.
We got to go check out my, if Porter is on here or Zach,
we got to go check on the pumps.
We got to go check all the font.
Like, dude, I'm driving around with dad, getting a lecture is the worst.
I know the stress.
Typically what we like to do is reminder Mike is during that first contract,
whether it's three months, whether it's six months, whether it's a year,
if you, if you go big boy and you do a big girl, big boy,
and you do a year right at the gate, that is the most important period.
Because if you can get them through that first contract into the second contract,
you're going to see your attrition go way down
and your attention go way up, which is the same thing.
So what we like to do is now it's a little bit different
because I have Francesca that can assist me with this,
but we like to check in weekly with these business owners
at least once a week for the first contract.
Now, typically what that looks like is maybe an email twice a month,
maybe a text message once a month, and maybe a phone call once a month.
Sometimes if they're a little bit like, you know, maybe with this one,
maybe it's a phone call three times a month and it's an email once.
And then the next week, it's like two calls and two emails.
And then the same the next, and it's like, okay, now they're happy.
We can kind of scale back, but I would be checking in at least once a week
until you get to contract number two, which is that year,
because then your attrition goes way down.
Okay.